je ressens maintenant le comédien michel
serrault pour la sortie en salles du
monde de marty michel serrault bonsoir
bonsoir très heureux de vous avoir pour
trois raisons d'abord parce que vous
aidera à la télévision oui mais je vais
vous dire une chose moi je vous quitte
pas parce que je vois tous les jours
voilà c'était la deuxième raison c'est
que vous êtes jeu c'est un
téléspectateur assidu et j'étais pas
content parce que la mode j'aime bien ça
mais on vous à vous un peu écourté la
part des prochaines normalement ça sera
les missions du rapport de l'année
j'écrirai vous me direz voilà vous
écrirez au patron de la chaîne
donc
vous êtes toujours le bienvenu ici
d'autant plus aujourd'hui que c'est
votre anniversaire donc je vous dis bon
anniversaire et vous êtes au courant de
tout de tout
alors est ce que vous dites que l'avenir
non encore votre avenir à booba je
pourrais dire que des bonnes choses
alors le monde de marty de denis bardiau
donc avec johnatan de mur j'ai sorti
mercredi alors je vais vous dire
franchement
l'histoire vont vous dans le film vous
êtes atteint de la maladie d'alzheimer
le petit là le cancer je me suis dit ça
va être franchement je suis d'ailleurs
pas être écolo me suis dit bon voilà et
force est de reconnaître avec plaisir
que je suis sorti de là enthousiasmé les
larmes aux yeux d'abord enthousiasmé
c'est un vrai hymne à la vie le mot est
un peu un peu bête mais c'est sami n'ont
pas brillé voilà et je suis sorti de là
le coeur le coeur gonflé de ça m'a fait
du bien et depuis je suis devenu le
meilleur agent de publicité de ce film
et je vous le dis à vous chères amies et
chers ennemis c'est vraiment un film qui
au début c'est un peu aride le sujet
mais c'est pas du tout excuser moi le
mot c'est pas du tout chien c'est
pendant tout le film on s'ennuie pas
vous vous êtes en va en parler vous êtes
exceptionnel le petit de murs génial
alors je vais dire le pitch oui donc
marty martin alors l'appel marty il a
dix ans il est hospitalisé
mais là le cancer il vadrouille dans
l'hôpital voilà et un jour il ouvre une
porte comme ça il en trouve une porte il
tombe sur vous beran antoine b ans
atteint de la maladie d aylmer paralysé
muet et donc pendant tout le film
d'ailleurs vous exprimer on va en parler
envoie fin ce qui est assez étonnant et
marty adoptent beran ce vieux malade il
adopte si ça devient son jouet
d'ailleurs il appelle immobile man ce
qui est assez rigolo et finalement bas
ils finissent par s'adapter l'un à
l'autre et à devenir amis et à sa portée
des choses mutuellement leurs va
regarder un petit extrait et puis on en
parle magnéto
on le connaît ce bruit
je connaissais dessus du wat
coup beaucop qu'est-ce que j'ai l'âme de
ces mots comme c'est sa mère ça le petit
voyou vous vouliez vous échapper parce
que ne se passera pas comme ça allait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le monde de marty donc de 2000 bardiau
avec évidemment michel serrault et john
hutton de mur j'ai alors bon on va pas
dire où se situe la cène parce que sinon
on va déflorer le scénario 1
martin ne traite pas ne vous traite pas
enfin ne traite pas aberrant comme un
malade et en fait c'est ça qui est le
plus étonnant début j'avais eu
finalement c'est le charme est érigée ni
des enfants c'est que pour lui cette
bombe c'est évident c'est pas grave je
veux dire que moi dans la vie ça m'est
arrivé d'aller voir des amis ou même des
parents quelquefois dans d état
désespéré on ne sait plus très bien
comment faire c'est plus quoi dire et le
gaucher n'a pas chassé l'innocence il
devient sont deux copains et ils vont
cheminer ensemble pendant quelques mois
et puis bon on voit bien d'ailleurs
qu'on a quand la femme de bairon vial se
mêlent elle tricote dernier une première
scène qui est génial c'est quand il a
l'argent sur la télé oui il ya la femme
qui dort vous vous êtes la réveiller
pouvez pas vous exprimer le gosse il
prend l'argent sur la télé pouvait pas
réagir et et avant de partir il coupe la
télé je ne fais que ça vous voilà c'est
ce que je veux dire à nos amis c'est que
c'est s'est jamais
misérabiliste sait jamais c'est toujours
beaucoup d'humour beaucoup de moi je
fais attention par exemple pour jouer le
rôle je voulais pas qu'ils se soient
leurs moyens etc bon bah ils parlent pas
ils étaient très handicapé mais je veux
dire que le l'humour il
et quand il s'exprime dans cette voix
off dont vous parliez tout à l'heure je
t on dit bon bah voilà il prend soin
puis l'est pas il n'est pas amorti quoi
il analysé il se défend alors ensemble
marty et béret on construise un monde où
est ce que c'est cette chambre c'est le
monde cette chambre que ce film a l'air
un peu d'une fable ça pas de réalisme
vraiment on va pas on voit pas les
médecins trop on venait enfin le
traitement etc
c'est la rencontre de ce vieux bonhomme
avec ce gosse à la quête extraordinaire
alors évidemment ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est à dire que c'est un
film plein d'espoir et écoutez c'est une
femme sur le fait qu'il n'est pas
inutile de de vivre et que presque mort
on peut être encore utile voilà c'est ça
en fait c'est ça qui donne la pêche
quand on voit l'exacte c'est ça c'est ça
en fait j'ai dit oui ce pour faire le
crime du 10 mai c'est assez
extraordinaire ça on ne peut être utile
jusqu'au bout dans les conditions les
plus pénibles en plus plus incroyables
mais on peu cher servir être utile
encore à quelque chose et à quelqu'un et
alors ce qui masque images et des idées
un peu bizarroïdes des ce qui m'amuse
beaucoup c'est que le vieux bonhomme et
le gosse ne sont pas au courant du
parcours qu'ils font ils ne savent pas
de résultats de leur amitié unités or le
résultat de l'amitié c'est que le le
gosse va vivre peut-être un peu grâce
aux vieux et lui le vieux va disparaître
mais heureux d'avoir d'avoir connu cette
aventure vous vont geler dit en
commençant c'est une vraie performance
d'acteur parce que dans ce film vous
dites me suis mis en état de médium
c'est un peu quand je m'amusais endormir
les gens au service militaire donc c'est
vrai quand vous étiez à dijon
si je sais tout ne se fait pas la guerre
ce n'est pas la guerre les aviez
hypnotise un étudiant sait pas quoi
faire et le soir
on avait des longues soirées jet qu'est
ce que je vous entends pas ce que j'ai
mais j'ai toujours aimé ça les fakirs
les intérêts et vie il n'ya pas des
bêtes qui veulent venir y avait toujours
des dégâts qui se proposait 10 mois en
mois tu meures dormira pas l'essayer et
allende et là vous exprimer vraiment
c'est formidable comme comme performance
d'acteur tout simplement c'est à dire
avec un battement de cils
sans un mot puisque évidemment vous ne
pouvez vous pouvez pas parler ce qu'on
peut dire si vous existez autant dans ce
film que zaza napoli dans la cage aux
folles quoi alors que c'est un
débordement de mots hélas ensemble sans
rien dire vous existez autant c'est à
dire on dit c'est pas d'acteur ça fait
nommer ne sait pas trop ce que c'est on
peut alors moi non mais ce qui est
extraordinaire je pense pas à la
présence des acteurs par exemple au
tertre c'est plus facile parce que vous
êtes en chair et en os et on vous voit
donc un ou s'étonnerait pas de voir un
acteur qui joue toute une pièce muet
serait là ne pourrait ne pas envoyer des
ondes il pourrait participer ils
pourraient au cinéma c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais je pense aussi que
totalement convaincu de ce qu on joue on
peut encore avec très peu de choses
faire passer des senti la passe ça passe
ça passe très bien on va vous continuez
quand même à prendre des risques parce
que
ce film quand on a dû vous la portez le
scénario quand même il faut avoir envie
de faire tu sais pas gai pour faire ça
faut être faut être gonflé en plus de
réalisateurs il n'est pas fait
grand-chose il avait eu un premier prix
un festival de courts métrages l'onisep
aouda par besson bardiau oui bon après
il avait fait un court métrage chapet
peinard d'ailleurs avec jaffré le
coscénariste et pas fait grand chose non
plus il ya plus est battu pour que le
film puisse se faire c'est à dire qu'à
un moment vous êtes enfin le secret
parce qu'évidemment quand on lit ça
personne n'y croit beaucoup d'émoi java
pas bon y a pas d'histoire de
ce point n'est pas une image mais il n'y
a pas de coups de cul si vous voulez il
n'y a pas de moins de piste d'allan il
ya un an il n'y a pas on peut pas se
réfugier dans l'est dans tout ça alors
c'est pas encourageant pour des gens qui
veulent faire de l'argent sans un volet
dit mais qui savait un sapin on faire
quand les enfants du marais vers les
enfants du marais quand ce film est
sorti la presse pas toute la presse
qu'une grande partie de la presse s'est
lui dit qu'est ce que c'est ce film-ci
réactionnaire cp tennis et même sur un
casillas des pétainistes et ça a été un
énorme succès donc moi je pense qu'un
film comme ça on ne sait jamais c'est ça
qui mirent à philou et dont j'étais un
peu en colère parce que systématiquement
je suis tombé ça a été un peu difficile
à monter ce sont des gens qui y
faisait racontée par des collaborateurs
parce que il ya très peu de gens qui
prennent des responsabilités et qu'il il
faut le dire
mais pour le dire donc lisez puis vous
verrez alors le petit acteur la
johnattan de murs gk 11 ans donc il a
commencé à 8 ans est aussi un bon acteur
c'est quelqu'un ensemble et il a eu la
salle ce soir d'ailleurs il commettait
un cascadeur sa mère joué dans des
séries à télé donc il va élever la dent
et ses grands-parents fait certainement
du cirque vous qu'est ce que vous
faisiez 11 ans au même âge on sent que
ce que j'étais un rongeur jeté dans la
rue ouais jeté dans la rue oui alors
j'allais au cirque parce que j'ai
toujours aimé le cirque et j'habitais la
banlieue et le spectateur sportif l'a
cédée au président jammeh oui j'avais
cru un copain des 10es de des
fortifications lui au boulevard
d'algérie et moi un but de la porte
brunet mais alors faut pas qu'on nous
emmerdent a été un beau petit voyou un
peu petit chef bon c'était pas les
loubards c'était des petits loubards de
bd des années des années nous piquer des
trucs qu'on a mais moi je voulais
voler c'est une époque ont volé pour
manger de rentrer à 3-4 dans une
boulangerie maintenant le patron willie
robert où je faisais il faut donner les
plombs et puis les machins oui y'en a
marre et alors déjà à l'époque vous
hésitiez quoi entre prête ou clown c'est
toujours ce côté non mais j'aimerais
fuji ce côté gay mystique pieux blagueur
vous hésitiez entre prêtres et clown
c'est vraiment oui ah ben oui c'est vrai
alors j'ai pas vu quelqu'un m'a dit ça
et récemment encore il m'a dit
finalement que j'allais faire il te
prouver
je n'ai pas encore de je prêche pas
encore non mais vous êtes croyants et
mais voilà vous avez été renvoyé alors
du conflent la du petit ses marques et
renvoyons non on a fait comprendre
gentiment que que je t'ai peut-être plus
doué pour le cirque peut-être où les
planches que pour pour leur l'homélie ou
pour annuler témoin bon je dis morieux
pourquoi pas les curés dans les films de
mots qui sait tout mais
alors devant ses fanfaronnades et votre
esprit comme ça un peu petits chefs
qu'on a du mal à quand on voit
maintenant vous êtes devenu tellement
radieux on imagine mal le petit je t'ai
pas méchant là ben non ça va non on
arrêtait les jeux dans le métro et
d'édition de légende normande et vichy
gare à toi les bras d un peu de tout
mais on n'a jamais frappé alors un jour
y ait quelqu'un qui vous a dit bah
écoute tu devrais aller au conservatoire
de la rue blanche l âge de 16 ans vous
avez vous avez voilà j'ai commencé comme
ça ces géants du don
est là en même temps vous avez continué
à aller aller au cirque parce qu'en fait
vous étiez vous dis que c'est vraiment
c'est mon premier spectacle la première
fois de jerry où j'étais éblouie par
l'est par la présence des clones qui
reste pas moins à nu un mystère j'adore
les mystères tout ce que je comprends
pas évidemment j'adore parce que ne peut
pas faire autrement va pas se fâcher
parce qu'on comprend pas ton j'adore
mais c'est vrai alors c'était pas que
vous faisait des petits spectacles comme
ça parallèlement au conservatoire vous
peignez les affiches à la main dans les
magasins je vais frontier vous faisiez
oui les gens pensent que poirée chéreau
par exemple on venait de chopin ou sait
plus d'où venaient en jean et moi on a
préparé le conservatoire et ouais on
voulait être des acteurs des acteurs
classiques qu'on a rejeté et alors on
est obligé de faire notre d'ouvrir nos
boutiques alors vous été virés justement
de la rue blanche après deux ans votre
premier contrat c'est dans 146 pour
détourner en allemagne et en france avec
jean marie serreau côté un grand ami et
quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup de talent
qu'est le papa de coline serreau ah bon
je savais pas que j'étais thériault a eu
alors 2 heures
du jamais vu ou samuel t alors pourquoi
vous a été viré du conservateur au bout
de deux ans parce que je venais pas où
je travaille pas suffisamment ou juillet
où
je n'ai jamais été fâché on me dit on le
disait comme on veut on peut me le dire
encore aller faire ça ailleurs une
jalouse à peyrusse pas encore jugé bon
on va voir un autre part on verra bien
parce que je crois que pour être
comédien il faut d'abord il faut pas
aller dans une boutique il faut regarder
un peu partout et j'ai eu la chance bien
j'étais jeune de me balader un peu
partout oui j'ai été j'ai pas été chez
jouve est parce qu il y avait plus de
cours à l'époque mais j'ai vu je
voudrais quand même jouer la comédie
mais j'allais chez dulin par exemple je
mets beaucoup je travaillais avec robert
de niro il ya quelqu'un qui a eu un peu
une expérience similaire à la vôtre de
la rue comme ça c'est luchini s'est
beaucoup promené dans la rue dans son
quartier près de la goutte d'or là bas
il a appris comme vous dans les
boutiques en regardant les gens savaient
ce qu'ont fait les uns et les autres les
médias c'est parce qu'on a des grandes
oreilles et des yeux et c'est ça quand
on vous dit est ce que vous avez
travaillé pour préparer le film où il
tournait à soixante dix ans que je
travaille et que l'autre jour il ya
quelqu'un qui m'a dit mal en vous
répéter chez vous parce que j'étais sur
le plateau jeudi avec clive et google
avec ma glace
ça d'abord je peux pas approvionner que
la glace en plus je sais pas toujours
qu'il va me donner la réplique donc ça
se passe sur le terrain cela va de soi
lorsque j'ai appris en préparant cette
interview en fait c'est que vous aviez
été je passe l'été son élève mais vous
aviez connu etienne decroux qu'est vous
dit enquêter le un professeur de mime et
ça a été le professeur de marchaux oui
c'est ça oui oui bien vous dit en
parlant de lui ce grand silencieux
auquel les élèves doivent tant
d'éloquence c'est con comme un
magnifique il avait aussi une formule
qui nous faisait rire à l'époque parce
que on passait beaucoup les acteurs et
faisait des stages il fallait prendre
l'expression corporelle le mime et elle
offre sa devise c'était un homme nu sur
une scène nue et les luttes et des
spectacles où il avait juste un petit
truc devant kafka mais autrement il
était tout nu et il faisait la machine à
vapeur la gueule toutefois la création
du monde c'est le summum du mime cette
solution alors les doses à poil et puis
on devrait faire une machine à coudre
une soupière a enfin
permis leur vais gérer
ça a des limites mais c'est pas mauvais
ce n est qu à part eau et l élève aussi
de jean-louis par audrey de le coincer
un croc en jambes et qui n'a pas fait
l'expression corporelle
il a tort parce que c'est bien les
acteurs font pas à cette danse
d'expression corporelle sont passés ils
nous apprennent pas la musique moi je
peux après tout ça j'avais un petit peu
un petit peu mais pas beaucoup mais je
pense que on peut pas apprendre vraiment
jouer la comédie il faut être curieux
mais il faut apprendre un travail comme
ça alors donc je filme dénis bardiau je
répète c'est le monde de martissant
mercredi ne vous laissez pas rebuter par
le pitch allez-y voilà un
mois j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir les
pas de réseau maison ils prennent pas du
pas un trait c'est un voilà alors vous
projet dont il ya le mot qui vous le
faites là est le mode qui j'ai vu moquer
ya pas longtemps il est en pourparlers
j'avais eu un coup de téléphone ya six
mois le film n'est pas encore monté et
lui dit alors tu pense à moi petit mail
à l'écouté je vous embêter mais ça va se
faire et c'est
long mais j'adore attention je sais bien
sûr donc ça fait la soutane turquoise
avec emmanuelle béart donc il doit se
monter le libertas assez tourné alors là
c'est fait sur le 22 mars et là bas son
père est fanny ardant alors lyon bat
c'est gabriel aghion qui avait fait ce
film que lui tellement de succès [ __ ]
douce cervin alors là je joue aux cartes
général alors vous allez vous allez voir
je suis pas de l'acteur pour terrible
mais comme cardinal et pourtant c'est la
soutane rouge sur le graphique des
paquets et les acteurs justement de
bertrand blier irak toute une pléiade
repasse à ça tout le monde attend c'est
bien qu'on ait on est quand même 35 rien
si on est obligé de nous mettre par
ordre alphabétique qui fait que moi avec
mon ce héros je suis à la fin de la
fiche de tout ça il faut passer par là
alors peut pas pour finir vous restez
avec nous pour le
300e sais pas pourquoi ne pas laver
souffrent bah oui parce que je suis
petit je ne pêche là honnêtement on veut
sur la peinture elle sait les derniers
justement vous fait long feu
vous avez dit une fois à l'époque
d'assassins s'était mal passé à cannes
non très bien avant et vous avez dit
franchement vous me voyez arrêté avant
de mourir
[Rires]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus